[Música]
no
de la luz fue vestir
y yo de dios
s
la verdad
[Música]
está feliz
en el hombre
[Música]
sólo para dar
en su dolor
[Música]
t
en el pueblo
[Música]
tuve que esperar
son
[Música]
yo
en la tierra
mi corazón
[Música]
d
espera
[Música]
sí
d
[Música]
sí
x
quiere
bien
ya
vaya
ah
y corazón
d
qué esperas
[Música]
la luz y el cuervo
muchas gracias
si trabaja el presidente mira con vista
a la gente y trabajan los obreros pero
no el dinero si trabaja el campesino y
ser pobre su destino si trabaja mi papá
y no le alcanza para nada
[Música]
a ella yo no vuelvo a trabajar para que
matar todos los sentidos
a ella ella yo no vuelvo
y yo no vuelvo a trabajar
ay
yo no bebo
[Música]
trabajad militar sólo sirve para hablar
y trabaja el carcelero pero él mismo es
prisionero y trabaje límpidas de gana
más con traficantes si trabaja el
congresista no hay pueblo que lo resista
a ella yo no vuelvo a trabajar para que
nada estas dos vidas
yo no
el boss
[Música]
para quemarse
y yo no vuelvo
[Música]
m
a ver
verdad
[Música]
pero
pero no
no
[Música]
a ella yo no vuelvo al trabajar para
quemarse las cosas que ella y yo
[Música]
a ella y yo no vuelvo a trabajar
[Aplausos]
a ver si cantamos a ella yo no vuelvo a
trabajar
[Música]
[Aplausos]
a ella yo no vuelvo a trabajar a ella
ella y yo no vuelvo a ella yo no vuelvo
atrás
[Música]
yo
vuelvo
yo no vuelvo
tarde
yo no vuelvas a bajar
a ella yo no vuelvo
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Risas]
[Música]
a quién te ha dicho que me he muerto
cuando perdido y han dado
este método
[Música]
sea libre
que no habrá sido el doliente que de mí
se habrá acordado
[Música]
viste bien sea alegre
ya estoy volviendo dejo causar el tiempo
mira
no quiero volverme
todo se vuelve verano
[Música]
o no
y yo soy músico
una cosa se ha puesto y otra se está
poniendo
[Música]
dejar la negra que te
para otra que anda
y queriendo
triste el rey no se alegre
[Música]
ah
no
es el mejor
de baja
está bien
nunca lleva de
no
bueno
ya llegué
[Música]
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]